cantando su primer mitin ante sus fans
espera déjame saludar a mis amigos para
su primer acto proselitista como
candidata oficial del partido socialista
francés la emoción se sentía en el aire
nacional es muy conocida en los círculos
internacionales y europeos es una mujer
y vamos a apoyarla pero no todos los
partidarios de la ciudad de mil están
convencidos de que pueda ganar tiene
trabajo por delante eso es seguro
las encuestas muestran que hay algo no
le está yendo bien ahora mismo la sitúan
en el noveno puesto para la primera
vuelta de las elecciones con sólo el 5%
de los votos su pálido comienzo es un
golpe para los socialistas en el mitin
de lille acudieron a prestarles su apoyo
líderes del mismo partido al que fue una
vez la principal fuerza política de
francia como la alcaldesa de lille es la
alcaldesa de parís oigo a la gente decir
a ellas la alcaldesa de parís y que eso
es algo de lo que hay que estar
orgulloso es la alcaldesa de parís
bryant por todo lo que haces y de algo
asegura que los electores están cansados
de lo que llamo la condescendencia del
gobierno de manuel makoun
en francia no hay un júpiter ni una
figura enviada por el cielo en francia
hay franceses que viven piensan y
merecen ser considerados
jiménez de la corte de axxion para los
miles de simpatizantes en la multitud
que vinieron de toda francia para el
mitin esto es sólo el comienzo
para ganar impulso realmente lo creo por
eso estoy aquí hoy a menos de seis meses
de las elecciones presidenciales y de
algo tiene que escalar una empinada
cuesta pero ella y sus partidarios dicen
que están preparados para poner en
marcha su campaña